we do want to have a look at a few
photographs cuz that's always light
relief number three today that we're
looking at in DC President Obama
presents the Medal of Honor to LC
Sherman Ross she's in the center and ina
bath on the left he told him they were
gorgeous and they were very pleased with
that they accept the medals on behalf of
their Jewish father army sergeant
william shemin an award was also given
to Army private Henry Johnson who was
african-american they were honored for
their actions in world war one it was
ordinary to change yes yes ordinary
story so long overdue it's amazing
absolutely incredible and they were so
graceful and so so honored it was
amazing all right number two in San
Francisco dry Queens and Native
Americans and domestic violence
survivors are protesting outside
Facebook's headquarters here in this
photograph didn't get shares on the IPO
that could be part of it I'm not sure
they would have wanted Sheri's in the
IPO who knows generalization they're
fighting though against the social
networks rule that people can only use
real names on facebook instead Native
Americans want to be able to use their
tribal names but they get kicked off
facebook because it's not listed on
their drivers license friend and are you
on vacation i am on facebook with my
real name i think this is fascinating
because this is strangely enough related
to the Arab Spring which is that there
were democratic activist groups in Egypt
who were frustrated with Facebook
because it kept on kicking them off as
they were organizing because they were
using pseudonyms so this is you know it
is a very strong principle in internet
you know social circles to use fake well
you need so fake so your real name
encourages better behavior we know that
studies have shown that if you're using
your real name you're not as obnoxious
online but they're very real reasons to
use your fake name there are but then
why don't you use of a social network
son you know me that was the innovation
of Facebook right that you had to be
yourself from that you couldn't they
didn't check for my driver's license
they didn't know I mean I they can know
if you use your real name they come are
you our legend dies no cos Gordy how are
we missing some no no I just Allanon
they verify with your email all right
there are I mean there were ways around
of them what else do we have any way
number one of the video the Galapagos
Islands the wolf volcano there began
spewing lava into the ocean volcano
erupted
in the last month for the first time in
33 years opposes no risk to people the
nearest villages 70 miles away look at
that the endangered species of pink
iguana that live on the volcano also
remain safe for now what color is lava
it's fairly pinch right I've actually
seen it in Hawaii I looks just like it
deserve this I love it when we get our
equal 0 toes in these videos it is
Bloomberg surveillance and volcanology a
report this is mrs. Eric our photo
editor who's like vulchy nombres again